[Music]
can you tell us you brought us a gift
you set up this entire little
moment what is going on here well today
is a very special day in new york and i
haven't been to new york
for over a year because the whole covet
thing but today my wine
company is going public on nasdaq
through a spac
in other words it got acquired into a
public company oh and that's a very big
day for us
we have been growing and growing and
growing for seven years we're now one of
the largest wine companies in north
america
and this is a you know big moment
because we'll be making lots of
announcements at 4 o'clock when i ring
the closing bell
wow any sneak peeks for us yeah i'll
tell you what but let me just put on my
very important elements when you're in
the wine business
explain what this is this is when i'm in
the cellar because i blend all the wines
or at least
the o'leary ones you're seeing we go
into the
oak caskets and we take a little siphon
called the thief
and put a little bit into here let it
mix with the air
taste it and then spit it out because if
you do that for every bottle you're
gonna get really wasted yeah so that's
the whole idea so the test of ambi has
become the symbol of wine making all
around the world
and there's very famous organizations
like the chevellier de testave
i love when you say that on church i'm a
member of and and
those of us who blend wines now these
two wines i brought
to celebrate with is my these are my
most award-winning wines and my biggest
sellers my chardonnay
it's more of the montreshe style which
is the french style of making chardonnay
very crisp very light less oak and then
my incredible cabernet sauvignon which
has won award after award after award
wow even andy our cameraman when he got
was proposed to his
his fiancee he took all the insurance
necessary which was two glasses of this
oh my gosh and she immediately said yes
i'll marry you that's right that's so oh
wow and you know what like i feel like
you've kind of made a mark for yourself
in shark tank as the wine guy
and when i met you i feel like a lot of
people don't know this but it's pretty
common you and your wife taught me that
you can tell
what kind of wine is in the bottle based
on the shape of the bottle is that
correct you can you can this is the
classic french cabernet
and that's the classic chardonnay now
what's happened
in america you know the most popular
wines today are the cabernet sauvignon
red and the chardonnay chardonnay
exploded when they started growing the
grapes in california decades ago
and they started competing globally and
and california shards started
kicking french shards butts a lot in
international contests where it's blind
taste testing
so the wine industry the american wine
industry particularly in washington
state
sonoma valley napa valley it's really a
big business now
but there's an old joke about the wine
business if you want to become a
millionaire in the wine business
start as a billionaire because everybody
blows their brains out
they make it a labor of love i'm in it
to make money
yeah and the only way you can make money
in the wine business is have huge scale
be able to ship millions of cases
be able to fulfill costco and target my
own wines
and the new trend which we've really
blown up big is 46 states allow you to
ship directly
to your customer remember a case of wine
weighs 39 pounds
yeah so if you get it direct it's coming
right to your door
and i have built that business up to
being the largest direct consumer in the
world
at least in north america i can't say
the globe yet because i don't know what
they're doing in china
right but i'll kick the chinese butts
too
yeah in kovit i mean direct to your home
wine
is every answer yeah and what happened
was people
didn't stop drinking wine during uh
covert but what
really got crushed was our business tube
restaurants yeah that's when we replaced
it with the direct consumer and
blew that business up even bigger yeah
and now people are saying i don't want
to you know carry 12 bottles back from
the store just shipped me another case
mr wonderful
yeah and i obliged so you i think one of
my favorite interesting facts about you
is
now you're conquering wine you've very
much made yourself the wine connoisseur
but what you don't get enough credit for
is you were also the original inventor
of a childhood staple of ours the oregon
trail
yes the oregon trail read a rabbit where
in the world's carmen san diego
all those titles yes and that's how i
came up that was my first business was
educational software
um oh my gosh i didn't know that yeah
that was it and we used to develop all
kinds of titles
you know oregon trail was an incredible
product because it started in
minneapolis i think minnesota and i
may have forgotten exactly which city
but i remember when we bought the title
we required it i was blown away by how
rich the storytelling was
yes your ox died of sedentary like it
was crazy yeah
you know people would try and get
through the brutal lifestyle of moving
west in you know in that time
but we invested a lot of money into it
and made it one of the standards of 110
000 school buildings in america
yes and i were among those schools right
it's literally a cornerstone like a
staple of millennial
like early education i like a very fond
memories of it yeah yeah
we sold that company for 4.2 billion
dollars very nice
and i started with nothing in the
basement you know sort of a garage thing
and the 10 of us that were founders that
was our big liquidity event
yeah and since then i've made many
mistakes but also made a couple of good
investments too so it was a really big
it was a big moment for us because we
really had nothing and then boom
and i remember the day we went back to
the office and i said everybody going to
do
we can all retire and everybody said i
don't want to retire
just keep going so you entered the wine
business as a billionaire
well yes but
but i've really learned a lot um from
the wine business
most of the companies that i've made
money with have been run by women
that i've invested in and the wine
business included
i remember um when it started it was
actually a shark tank deal years and
years ago called zip swine
single serve wine oh i remember of
course yeah you guys went back and forth
back
yes and it was one of the famous first
time a guy ever came back twice
yes and but but i'll tell you the story
of that the day after that
aired i won the deal i thought the place
to get this into would be costco
yeah and there's a very famous story
about costco this woman nate
and a woman named annette alvarez who
started
in costco in florida in miami sweeping
floors
she had such an incredible palette to
taste wine
that she quickly moved up the ranks to
the regional buyer and then she became
the
national buyer and then the head buyer
for the whole of costco and what you
have to know is costco is the largest
wine buyer
in the world period not nobody's
bigger anywhere on earth so they get
everything she had 12
buyers underneath her and it was also
known that nobody could ever get to her
every wine company in the world wanted
to talk to her but she just wouldn't
take calls
so after shark tank i thought i wonder
if she's a shark tank fan
and i've got a guy on my staff that goes
into the dark net knows how to get cell
numbers
and so he got her cell number for me and
i called it
and i left her a message saying hey it's
kevin warren shark tank i have no idea
if you uh
watch the show at all but i have this
product called zips i'd like to show it
to you
20 minutes later the phone rings it's
annette alvarez and she says
you were rude to barbara last night
what what does that have to do with
anything she said no we're not doing any
business until you apologize to barbara
wow
i said what did i do wrong she said you
were rude to her you cut her off she was
speaking
i said that happens every day on shark
tank yeah plus you want to have less out
of barbara not more
anyways we made it work and she said
look i'll give you one hour
john wayne airport this saturday and i
want to meet your wife oh wow
i want to know who would marry a guy
like you right i said
okay and i said linda we're going to
john wayne airport we're going to meet
annette alvarez
and here's where it all starts we meet
her we sit down with her she says kevin
let me tell you about the wine business
you don't know
if you want to make money in the wine
business and not be one of these schmoes
that just starts a little winery and
says oh look i got a winery
you have to be able to ship me 150 000
cases in a day
wow i said and that i can't do that she
said you can
if you partner with vintage wine estates
a guy named pat roney
you go cut a deal with him you come back
to me and watch what happens
and she was the woman who gave me the
advice that turned this whole thing and
blew it up and now we're going public
today
wow well congrats yes but i'm just
telling you listen to women sometimes
all the time i'm just so i i shut up and
listen a lot because that was great
great information that's so interesting
and you know because it's very you know
you see you on shark tank it's such a
big show and i think a lot of people
are on the misconception that that's not
all you do you know like you're a famous
person now
who made you know his billions on your
educational company
and now you just are a famous person who
does shark tank but you're still very
much active in a lot of companies
correct yeah i have 35 plus portfolio
companies
across a wide range of activities
everything in commercial kitchens
we do insecticides we've got wireless
charging companies we make
a very famous gym equipment for
condominiums here in new york that
business exploded during cobit
we have the wine business obviously and
many many many others
i will tell you something each day
there's a catastrophe in some part of my
business
you know portfolio some something
horrible is happening
at the same time the phone rings in as
some euphoric outcome
that somebody's buying another one of
our businesses right and it's just like
a
passion play every day yeah you know on
one end total [ __ ] on the other
side fantastic things yeah i've kind of
gotten into the groove now and i say
well
okay that's just the way it's going to
be yeah you can't make everything work
and then every once in a while boom it
hits
it hits big so how many
an estimate how many companies do you
think you've invested in from shark tank
oh it's got to be pro maybe over 100 by
now i've been doing this for 13 years
and how many an estimate do you think
you've made a pretty good return on
well what happens is let me give you the
ratio because we've got all this data
in normal venture capital when when you
you know go to boston and talk
to silicon valley to a venture capital
firm they do 10 deals and you look over
eight years what happens two of them are
absolutely wild successes they make
40 50 times on their money and then
about
four of them um are living dead they're
still in business but they're just
barely getting by barely getting by and
unfortunately waste a lot of your time
and the rest go to zero and so it's sort
of you know 20
work in the real world in shark tank 50
work and here's why here's the secret
sauce
so 50 of our deals make money because
see how we're sitting here doing social
media and you you reach out and you've
got millions of people listening to you
your customer acquisition costs are very
low yes right
we get 100 million eyeballs a year on
shark tank through syndication in 23
countries
so when we put a product on shark tank
it's not uncommon to get all your money
back in 24 hours yeah oh wow
yeah exactly what happens and so our
customer acquisition costs
are either zero or very low so even a
marginal company
a shitty company that can't acquire
customers gets this
jolt yeah of of you know free
advertising
for decades yeah yeah and boom they just
keep selling stuff and we have all this
stuff documented
the rise so the whole thing about shark
tank is getting on shark tank yeah and
if you can get a deal
then you get the updates which are
really powerful some companies i love
the updates beyond the table
beyond the tank we love we love but you
know you get more sales on updates
sometimes you get on the main show huh
so you want to get a deal that's the
secret sauce to shark tank
that's so interesting what's your
favorite category or type of product
that comes into the tank when you're
like
oh i'm listening to this one i love
companies
you know right across the board every
category included
that has already figured out social
media
and direct to consumer sales and they
know their customer acquisition cost
when they walk on that set and say look
we don't sell retail we sell direct to
consumer
and here's our customer acquisition jobs
here's the margins we make
all i'm doing then is pouring gasoline
on the fire if they're asking for a
million bucks i'm happy to give it to
them
yeah because what's going to happen is
we're going to just blow that business
up because they've solved all the
problems already
like the infrastructure's already there
exactly and the ones that i
those those are the deals i tend to do
anything run by a woman gets priority
for me because i've made so much money
with women i'm just
you know i'm biased in some ways i
shouldn't be but it's fair women
tend to mitigate risk you know that old
expression you want something done give
it to a busy mother
yeah like they can keep a lot of stuff
in the air once and that's what you need
in a small business
and also they're much more savvy on
social media yes
and women are more likely to engage and
share on social so you want a woman
speaking to them and well the same way
you do it you know you connect with
these
you know other people and they they just
want to hear what what's next from you
right well companies that have figured
that out have very very powerful
business models yeah
and so what would you say is your most
successful business
investment from shark tank is it plated
even though that was it's a new york
city
deal in some sense right it was started
here by a couple of entrepreneurs
they came on the show they had a
ridiculous valuation they didn't get a
deal a year later
they run into me in the street and say
hey listen we've been tenderized by the
real world
we're willing to cut a deal and so we do
it we do a deal and then
they get back into the tank in a
follow-up and then one day we get a call
from albertsons right after
amazon bought whole foods and said we
need to buy a digital platform
right 340 million smackaroos
wow business was like 36 months old so
those dudes rode into the sunset
that's amazing we love so many of the
episodes where you have guest sharks we
learned so much from them who was your
dream
guest shark for the tank have they
already been on
well no no my dream guest shark is mr
wonderful
i love you i love that i love that guy
yeah we've had a lot of guest sharks
we've had all kinds of guest sharks
um some are better than others
some you know what happens with shark
tank and this includes all the people
that come and pitch
they you know a hundred thousand people
apply
340 get picked 220 get taped maybe 180
air
wow okay so here's what happens you've
been practicing for months
you know you're going to get on that
carpet yeah
and then you walk out the door
the museum practiced now it's real
yeah 26 cameras rolling jibs moving down
you know
steadicam all around you and you freeze
yeah yeah
yeah it's sometimes it's painful i have
to say like at least for me
i can think of one episode in particular
that will for me ever go down as the
worst pitch ever
um and he actually went to your college
yeah i think that's why i remember him
he had that app that was like basically
a map of the airport and it would help
you like find restaurants
and and he remembered and he was like
such a classic millennial like needing
validation and then he went back and he
was like crying in his mom's arms like
it was just all so
like funny but he sucks and when the app
was like he was going around to
different airports and writing down like
where there was no real like
infrastructure like
do you have like memories or things that
you like always will remember as being
like funny or particularly like terrible
you know i get in a lot of trouble for
being the mean shark i'm not the mean
shocker just tell the truth yeah
when it sucks it sucks yeah okay and
it's very important that they know it
sucks so that they don't do it again
stop sucking yeah like try and come up
with something better
and then come back we've had people come
back but it's really a bad idea if it's
going to go to zero and you take your
family's mortgage down you know
yeah it's just crazy well yeah you seem
like you're very much on like the tough
love side of things well i'm just the
truth and if you can't deal with me
imagine the real world what's gonna do
to you
yeah you're gonna get fried and so
that's my attitude but you know i gotta
listen to barbara
and i gotta listen to lori yeah you know
you seem like you love it like it's a
great part of your job yeah but they
you know what they do is they say well
look i'm not gonna invest in you
this is barb all the time i'm not going
to invest in you but you keep doing what
you're doing and i look at her and say
what are you doing
like don't you have any morals you guys
have such a great dynamic i'm curious
is that first show and you guys act like
that behind like off the screen too
you you all have a crazy day we're like
friends we've been dealing with each
other
for over 10 13 years so
we try and be cordial i've you know we
but we're competitors yeah we're
competing for deals and and
we like each other and all that stuff um
barbara's a great cook when i'm in new
york i'll often go and have dinner with
her she's great
uh we're also incredibly busy yeah
i've i've never seen all the sharks get
in a room
during the off season ever it's
impossible to get them back together
nothing for a birthday party
well we can't but everybody's so
everywhere
and so the only date we know we're going
to see each other all together is the
first shoot date
of shark tank when we just clear our
schedules and we go do it right
yeah it's such a great show it's become
such like a
a part of like american culture and like
business and the business education i
think that especially for us that i
think for so many people like everything
we know about business like
we know from shark so no one thought
that would happen
um certainly most people thought
business would be boring yeah
that did not turn out to be the case i
remember the moment
that it all changed i'll never forget it
i think it was boston logan airport
i've been doing shark tank for three
years no one knew anything about it
nobody watched it it was just you know
the only people watching were two dogs
and a cat
that was about it but all of a sudden in
year
four something happened you know it was
the it was
coming out of that really big financial
crisis in 2008
and entrepreneurship started to be very
hip and shark tank caught on and i was i
went to the uh i was with my wife and
daughter
at um at the airport and i went into
men's room
and i you know was at the urinal doing
my business and there's a guy to my
right
two over right and he kept looking at me
and and i've noticed he kept looking at
me and he said are you that guy on shark
tank
i said yeah that's the first time it
ever happened he said you're an
[ __ ] and i said why would you say
that i said last night on shark tank you
took 51
of a startup that's outrageous business
business i said hey it's my money i'll
cry if i want to what are you talking
about
i said to him listen uh a lot of people
make deals in bathrooms but not here
today my friend
right i'm gonna run my business the way
i see i should 100
and he couldn't have known uh that
lyndon savannah are out there
he goes outside and i find out later
that he said to linda
that [ __ ] kevin o'leary's in the
men's room i didn't know it was your
wife
no and she said i know oh my god
no it's really an amazing show and i
feel like before
shark tank entrepreneur meant unemployed
and now it really means like it's
you've shaped a culture around the word
and it's something people want to aspire
to be and start their own businesses and
i just love it
we do we love you talking about what
you've done here because you're the girl
that's
basically telling everybody you're
unemployed yeah you're a comedian
which is erratic work to say the best
and then
you come in here you know with your
sister every day and you produce
this which is actually been very
successful for you
so yes you're unemployed but you're
making money right it's a beautiful
poetic irony of it all
it is but i wonder how many millennials
now
even gen zirs are going to look at your
model both of you and say
i need to do that because i you have
control over your own destiny
yes i think we're living in a world
where kids today want to grow up to be
influencers podcasters because part of
the job is to make it look easy you know
take beautiful photos filter everything
what a lot of people don't see is
a lot of the job is boring paperwork
like you would do at any other nine to
five to job
but influencing is the one industry
that's literal sole purpose is to make
it look fabulous make it look fun make
it look easy make it look
you know easy road to money and fame
when in reality it's actually a lot of
work and
we do a daily podcast which is crazy
because most people do weekly podcasts
and i can't count on my hand the number
of podcasts that launch and never go
past 10 episodes
even producing one episode a week is
incredible hard work so it's just one of
those things that looks super easy
um and i think that's why a lot of
people want to do it it looks like it's
the you know the fast track
to money and fame when in reality it's
like actually the opposite
but it's more than that because you know
if you ask
millennials eight out of ten will say
i'm going to be an influencer
you can't just become an influencer the
market is really cruel that way
it it you have to have something about
you maybe
you know your story the fact that you're
a comic that
that gives the magnetism that creates
an interest for other people most people
don't have that
yeah well it's so saturated right now
like it's not only saturated breaking
through
even if you have it is next to
impossible yes getting your first
million followers is really really hard
let alone a hundred thousand
and so you really can't get traction
until you get scale
yes yeah and what i've learned you know
dealing with
all the influencers that i deal with and
the stuff we do is
that unfortunately for some people
they don't realize early enough that
people smell [ __ ] a mile away
yes and you when you get cancelled
you're cancelled yeah
you ain't coming back well we might be
back
i actually whack them all we wrote the
book on cancellation and cancel culture
literally
and i actually disagree i think we're
living in a really interesting time
right now where it's like a rubber band
that's going to snap
i think that for a while it was that was
the case like if you had even a sting of
scandal or controversy what about all
these people that got me toot
yes so we feel like cancel culture is
this huge bubble where we're like always
canceling people
for saying bad things and doing bad
things but actually the two of them are
incredibly different
if you were me too you are a criminal
like that is
separate we're talking about cancel
culture you know you have tweets
resurfaced from when you're in high
school you make a joke that not everyone
thinks is funny because you know we're
living in overly sensitive times like
that type of cancer culture's so toxic
because first of all it leaves
no room for growth okay roseanne barr
oh um i'll tell you why i bring that one
up okay
she changed forever the morality
contracts in hollywood that i was
subject to
in subsequent contracts your you know
the story just so we bring it to viewers
to understand here
and and i want to hear your response
because yeah not necessarily right
she did she said something very off
color yes
very that was her comedy 10 years ago
yes okay um
the network that was sponsoring the
number one show had 80 million i think
68 million worth of
up advertising the ceo canceled it
an hour and a half later gave all the
money back to the advertisers
yeah canceled the show
that's extreme yes because i do think
her tweet was incredibly
wrong where does it fit in your
continuum i'm trying to press the
we like to say that every cancellation
is not one size fits all i need to know
all the details so
you know that for that for that roseanne
thing like she was a however old she is
like a 50 year old woman like saying
something in present times
that she really should not have said
like i don't i actually think like her
being removed from the show was the best
thing for it
i don't know if the show needed to be
cancelled in its entirety there were
other people working on the show
120 people 100 yeah they brought it back
in
in a different format and i think a lot
of people got their jobs back but and
it's still on and it's successful
look i'm not endorsing what she said but
i'm pointing out to you that these
extremes on cancellation are
really serious yes and and has
materially affected her ability to get
back into her business
yes and so it was horrible what she did
yes
that was her comedy yeah there has to be
consequence like we live in a time and i
think we've all kind of come to the
realization we live in a time
that's very different than the time that
was 10 years ago and we all need to
adjust and i think that if you're still
saying
certain things in this day and age like
there are consequences for what you say
but i don't think that people should be
held
to the same standard you make a joke in
2010 and it resurfaces in 2021
that's not fair we're living in
different times well then then you're
right in that case because
i don't think you can be sexist or
racist period
not now not back then not in the future
i don't think that's a good thing for
anybody
and i think that's what got her in real
trouble
um because she took something that maybe
she thought could pass 10 years ago and
tried it out today and then
yeah done so you're the same i assume
comedy is a really interesting space
well that's what i wanted to probe into
right so comedy like most comedians have
podcasts and comedy and podcasting
couldn't be more different
comedy is no holds barred you
people fight for the right to say
whatever they want because it's a joke
and you should be able to make a joke
about anything
whereas podcasting comes from the
digital space and the digital space is
so sensitive there's many classic comics
that are really really
on the edge dave chappelle on the edge
on
sexist racist stuff like can you do you
can't do that anymore
no my talking about comedy in the
comments
really laying it out there my personal
style of comedy is
very specific and intentional like i do
self-deprecating comedy i make fun of
myself
because no one can be mad at you if
you're making fun of yourself you're not
offending anyone i'm literally just
defending myself
okay so you think those comics have to
change they can't do their traditional
routines anymore
i think comedy is like the last
remaining corner of the
earth where you can say crazy things but
i don't think it'll last long
it's already very touchy you're saying
you won't last long
yeah one won't no still i think a
a frontier that's in question i think
people are sticking up for
the right to joke about what you want to
joke about and then there are people who
are like we
you can't make jokes about that and i
think depending on the comedian or
depending on the celebrity or influencer
when we say like you can be canceled and
you can come back
you have to pull yourself up by the
bootstraps no corporation's going to
give you a job
no what brand is going to endorse you
like you need to make build your own
best for yourself
because the industry in the world that
we live in is not going to give you
canceled in a sense you can't go into
mainstream you have to do it yourself
yes
and you need to find your audience and
you like you
have to start from scratch and then you
build something
that is impenetrable you are in charge
of your own destiny
no one can cancel you because you own
your own show you make all your own
revenue you make your own merch like you
don't rely on any other company
a larger company and we're you know in
these extremely sensitive times like
that's corporate culture yeah yeah i
think this
this this model you've developed for
yourselves actually proven it out
is is very desirable for many people
want to control their own destiny
yeah i think you work harder than you
would in a corporate environment you
have more risk in your life because you
don't know what can happen
you have to put up your own money when
you start it and you also may make one
mistake and get fried and have to start
again
yeah but the beautiful thing about the
internet is that like it's just the wild
west so you can do
anything you want and there's so many
people on it like we've just kind of
cycled through so many different stages
of our business we're entering a new one
every week like that's just you have to
keep up with it and like you have to
shed your old skin and just
keep moving forward if you want to stay
in this industry for a long time
i think you do don't you of course
you've bypassed
all the traditional media like it used
to be you'll never get on this network
again you'll never get this you'll never
get that and it was all controlled by
hollywood agents and all that stuff into
a certain extent television still is
that way
but you know i have more followers now
than
most of the networks i'm on yeah right
and and it's a strange phenomenon that
you know i can reposition that content
modify it somewhat and get to a brand
new audience in a different way
yeah i'm not sure the model doesn't keep
going in that direction
and that you know linear television
continues to decline as social you know
this is kind of like social network
itself
you know every influencer podcaster
whatever becomes their own little media
industry and
the bigger you get you do almost have
more reach think of like podcasting
versus radio radio is
you know huge a lot of podcasts reach
more people than
traditional radio shows do podcasts used
to be framed
you know what i like to i get invited on
a lot of podcasts including this one and
what i like to do is
resist the temptation to go look at all
the previous
podcasts i don't want to know anything
about you
when i show up here i mean i met you for
a few hours right on an island
i thought i was thoroughly entertained
but i want to go in fresh yeah and then
later you know if we start doing it over
and over again i kind of get the groove
of where it is
but i've been much more successful doing
that in terms of engaging
and podcasts aren't just audio anymore
they're they're video yeah
that's what a podcast is it's just
another television show yeah
literally and my attitude is it's much
fresher when you go in
cold yes i agree you know i hate all the
scripted stuff and everything else
i just did the pomps podcast in miami
last week we had a
crazy amount of fun because we said no
questions pre
you know set yeah let's just see what
happens yeah yeah that was fun
that's the way it should be definitely a
refreshing format you're not
bound by those restraints of even
cursing like something as simple as that
right
time constraints like you can really go
for topic matter who knows
where you go right right exactly from
wine to roseanne barr yeah exactly but i
think those are serious issues
let's go back to wine because i want to
taste i want to try i want to give you
we're going to start with the
chardonnay even though it's not chilled
but this shard just won its
fifth gold award oh wow now let me tell
you something about the wine business
just before we pour this
um 97 of wine in america
is sold for under 14.99 a bottle wow
nobody knows that that means three
percent which is virtually nothing is
are those expensive wines
the challenge becomes how do you make a
wine that tastes like it's worth 60
that you can buy for 11. and i spent a
lot of time on this because i wanted my
return rates because i'm going direct to
consumer to be less than two percent
which was my goal
they're significantly less than one
percent wow so that means i have to kind
of adapt to the palette
most women drink pinot grigio and
chardonnay
that's you know they drink whites yeah
so you
need to work with a lot of women to
stamp like i'll blend it
i'll try it on my wife try it on her
friends then do some serious
taste testing sampling to get the vibe
from what a
miami woman says versus a california
woman versus somebody in champaign
urbana
to try and nail down do i have it
yeah because i'm i'm blending these
wines i'm adding little elements of
other varietals to get that flavor
about five years ago i hit it big when i
i started taking less you know when you
put chardonnay into an oak barrel
it gets buttery oaky and women were
moving away from that they were saying
give me something fresher it's too heavy
you know
and i went in that direction and then i
started winning the war cycle oh i'm so
excited to try this i'm usually not a
huge
chardonnay fan but i love sauvignon
blanc pinot grigio sounds sare
but if you're saying this isn't like a
buttery heavy chardonnay
way off in that direction which is
actually classic mantra shea style which
is what the french do in the drc region
of france
so let's try this how much is that
bottle this bottle
uh tonight the reason i'm talking about
it uh when we go public we're going to
do a giant sale on qvc
normally it would be 15.99 tonight it's
gonna be eleven dollars and twelve cents
15.99 is still a great price it's but
that we're going to sell
i did something remarkable a few weeks
ago on qvc in 20 hours we sold
5.2 million dollars worth of wow wow
yeah did you work with lori no i worked
with mr wonderful
yeah no listen you know i'm the wine guy
in qvc now because i think people trust
me when i say i have your back
i really know what i'm talking about i
would trust you like to choose a wine
for me will you also show us the right
way to taste
wine without looking like a fool
absolutely great question
we have these we have these coveted
glasses which are fantastic yes
so normally you would never overfill a
glass of wine you have to leave enough
space
the air to mix with the wine so you can
swill it a little bit good to know
it smells delightful yeah now let's do
this because this should be chilled but
it's not
because it came to the studio um
now the nose you should be picking up
some apricot and apple here
yeah okay so now take a little bit and
just
let it roll back in the back of your
tongue
stunning nectar from the nipple of
aphrodite
no it's really delicious so good it's
fantastic i actually don't drink wine
but
crisp it is it's not over sweet it's
towards what you liked in the dryness
yes this is a monster for me this wine
is my number one seller in white
really it's delightful it is delicious
stunning color as well
yeah it's beautiful and so you know this
kind of wine would be fantastic with
cheese it would be great in the
summertime
terrific with chicken people like to
drink it i always drink a glass of white
at four o'clock when the market closes
and i have one sometimes two and then i
go to my reds
so we're going to go to red next okay
well this was
chardonnay it was good stunning and
here sometimes you can be a realization
stick your pinky out like this when
you're drinking see that oh yeah because
we're fancy like that
exactly and you you know you're drinking
with a dork when you do that
yes someone uncultured yeah and now this
is a
cabernet sauvignon is known for being
the big spicy american red
you know for for with meat and just a
big bold statement
and what you're looking for here is um
peppers and tannins and
leather and just just richness
and get this by blending it again and so
many people don't understand that to get
the the tail of the flavor
you have to you know maybe you sneak in
two percent pinot
or maybe you put in a syrah or something
you have to blend you have to sit
in the cellar for days with your
testimony
and try different stuff while not
getting inebriated because you
you start you stop sensing the flavor so
most
of the time i'm tasting one and spitting
it out spittoon
so here we go now this is going to have
a huge nose
also five different awards on this one
oh wow
the red wine with the white carpet is
yeah
when's the last time you did a wine
tasting here never never we've never
done it on the show
okay so here we go it's good to start
with the best it can only go down from
here
yeah all right so again smells lovely
we really want to you know definitely
yeah i don't want to see that drop yeah
okay
now this is going to have
um a peppery kind of spice to
it and the more if you waited 10 minutes
it would even be more bold
because it's just airing this is going
to be really good i can tell
okay let's go ready
oh wow
that is fantastic it's very good it is
you know i never drink red wine
but it's very good isn't that delicious
yeah people tell me all the time i
really taste the pepper
yeah you see it it's there that took a
long long many years i've been doing
this wine for seven different years
of different varietals and started
winning about four years ago
when i started blending but you know
you've got to try new things in wine and
by the way the health attributes of one
glass of red
a year a day forever all year long
works in longevity yes it's good for
your heart everything and so you don't
have to get drunk you can just drink one
glass of nine ounces of red wine a day
and almost consider it medicine you also
could get drunk if you want
well that happens to me quite often
oops all right so where can everyone buy
o'leary wines on qvc you're having a big
sale
well there's what i've learned is this
is the business side again
wine is three tiers of distribution so i
used to give all my profits to
distributors
then i learned how to sell direct when i
got my social chops together and i
started small but now i'm huge
so you can buy o'leary fine wines at
shop mr wonderful
starting tonight at midnight wow we do
our big sale and that
site's going to stay up forever we're
announcing it at the nasdaq at four
you're getting a sneak peek
this won't be up until tomorrow anytime
on qvc.com fabulous
largest purveyor of wine and we ship it
to you directly
wow that's pretty awesome
it is great a lot of people go on to the
program where they get shipped a case
every 60 days
excuse me they sit they put it in a in a
like a laid down kind of wine cellar box
you stick it in the back of your closet
boom you got wine all the time for
forever yeah
[Music]
claudia and her sister were fantastic i
mean it was quite impressive of what
they built up there they're basically
their own network so
she controls it she publishes out the
content she makes money
um it's really quite remarkable but
what's relevant about her and her sister
they know what they're talking about so
their content really means something
because it's either it's heartfelt or
it's factual and i think that's probably
a
pretty good rule to understand about if
you're going to be putting something out
every day
you've got to have a lot a lot of topic
matters you know something about her do
some research but clearly they have
plus they're fun that was a gas i really
enjoyed it and
got to promote my wine which i thought
was terrific and
talked about a lot of interesting things
i'm glad i went there
where am i going dressed like this to
close the bell at the nasdaq
why because vintage wine estates the
company that makes all of the o'leary
fine wine
is going public today fantastic
bringing the bell is an honor celebrates
capitalism celebrates both
business celebrates entrepreneurship
particularly at the nasdaq
what a wonderful thing to do and then
what are we gonna do oh yeah baby we're
gonna drink some
very fine wine
patron the ceo is going to ring the bell
it's a big deal this is
actually the first day of trading for
vintage united states incredible stocks
up almost 20 percent
very good sign for the future
spectacular you know
have been controversial but not this one
this one has gained value since it got
announced which is absolutely great
glad to be a shareholder
[Music]
here's the secret about the very fine
wines you can't do that without having a
huge
infrastructure behind you the ability to
ship
tens of thousands of cases on a wine
sale that's really hard to do
how does it happen this guy this is pat
roney i met him years and years a year
and years and years ago introduced
by costco and we started a partnership
and wow
wow where does it end up here we are
ringing the bell at nasdaq it's
incredible
it's a wonderful outcome i want to say
thank you pat i want to thank you thank
you kevin it's been great
it's been so much fun working with you
on all on your wine well the best is yet
to come right yeah exactly
yeah more exciting we have really big
plans because we're going to expand this
direct to consumer i want to be a part
of that
that's the amazing thing about the new
world selling direct to consumer
cuts out all the middlemen the margins
are much better the business grows and
you have a relationship with your
customer
that's the plan that's the plan
absolutely the plan i'm
looking forward to executing that plan
it's a lot of exciting plans and
hopefully we'll get to and some of those
very soon
and it's all about the grapes yeah it's
all about the grapes and wonderful wines
that's mr wonderful
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe